16h56 aborde tous les bâtiments de la
force h
l'escadre britannique qui est là devant
mers-el-kébir
[Musique]
oh
aborde tous les bâtiments tu le même
voyant rouge qui s'allume le même mot le
même cri
ça y est voilà l'avenir sal
les obus qui jaillissent des long canon
de métal mais au but qui vole vers leur
objectif est l'objectif de la flotte
anglaise c'est la flotte française qui
est là
la mer celtique
[Musique]
jules roy était avec nous ou droit parce
que ce grand écrivain est né là-bas en
algérie
[Musique]
parce que justement il s'est senti
davantage concernés que d'autres par la
tragédie ne verse quelques habits et
puis parce qu après 43 ans de méditation
sur mers-el-kébir il vient de publier un
livre superbe
alors là cet sera magnifique
nous l'avons revu
et nous avons compris que les romains
déjà il ya bien longtemps l'avait
admirer utilisé savez vous comment ils
l'appelaient il appelait porthus divine
nusport divin ce hadith ou non et puis
après les espagnols ils avaient appelé
l'endroit marzal qui
il ya des traces de leur présence il y à
des forts ici et là il ya là haut sur la
montagne santa concis beaucoup de noms
espagnol partout et le 3 juillet 1940
[Musique]
s'il y a une flotte française
mers-el-kébir c'est parce que depuis
1870 les français succédant aux
espagnols et aux turcs ont décidé de se
servir de la rade comme d'une base et
c'est entre les deux gays que l'amiral
darlan donnant à la flotte française une
fabuleuse expansion en faisant la
quatrième flotte du monde à penser qu'il
faudrait un asile pour cette flotte
grandissante en méditerranée et c'est
pour ça que on s'est installé à marcel
kébir on a construit des jeter des
darses des môles des sémaphores on a
creusé le rocher pourrait ménager des
abris c'est devenu une très bonne base
en 1939 un décret la désigner comme base
de première série
dans cette base se trouve justement le 3
juillet 1940 une flotte
considérables sous le commandement de
l'amiral jean soul
voilà le nombre annoncé le non
essentiels de cette histoire nous allons
sans cesse parler de gens soul ce soit
et c'est darlan l' amiral de la flotte
qui va le nommer au commandement de
l'escadre de l'atlantique en motion
magnifique et quand la guerre éclate une
se bat dans l'atlantique qui ailleurs
coude à coude avec les anglais
et puis qu'on la menace d'une
déclaration de guerre italienne se
précise
d'accord entre eux anglais français
pensent qu'il faut que les ce cadre de
l'atlantique gagne mersen et b
[Musique]
on
le fait le 27 avril 1940 elle y est
toujours le 3 juillet 1940 et ce jour-là
à 6h45 du matin
on vient annoncer agences ou qu'un
navire anglais s'est présenté devant la
passe il s'appelle le fox awad un petit
détail ça veut dire chiens courants pour
chasser le renard est ce qu'on l'a fait
exprès je ne pense pas et ce bateau
exprime parce que on lit à son mât par
signal optique
cette formule nous avons à notre bord
commandant hollande demandons
autorisation entrer dans la passe et
perplexité de jean soul
qu'est ce que vient faire ce bateau qu'à
ce qu'il vient faire jean soûlât dit
plus tard
que d'abord il ne s'était pas douter de
la raison de la présence du fox un monde
bien difficile accord
voyons gensoul ne peut pas oublier que
le 24 juin précédent un autre bateau
britannique s'est présenté devant mais
recèle kébé et que à bord de ce bateau
se trouvait la mayral nord et willam
herald ans commandant de l'escadre
anglaise de l'atlantique qui l'a bien
connu
puisqu'ils ont travaillé ensemble
[Musique]
savait finalement tous ces gens ce petit
milieu de la marine aussi bien française
que britannique de ce collectif et
connor ce nul le voir gensoul elle a
reçu a mordu dunkerque et north est venu
lui poser une question
annette eu lieu dit enfin jean soul est
ce que au cas où nous volent demanderiez
vous accepteriez de rejoindre avec votre
flotte française notre flotte anglaise
pour continuer le combat coude à coude
contre l'allemagne contre l'italie
[Musique]
les gens soul a répondu avec une extrême
dect et non non parce que notre
gouvernement a signé l'armistice
et que notre devoir de marin c'est
d'obéir au gouvernement et que justement
pour tenir tête aux vainqueurs
qui occupe la plus grande partie du
territoire français qui détient 1
million 500 mille prisonniers dans les
camps allemands
pour tenir tête à ce vainqueur le
gouvernement ne dispose que d'un atout
et c'est la flotte alors moi je n'ai pas
le droit gensoul désobéir au
gouvernement alors nord c'était parti il
avait fait un rapport il ne se rendront
jamais à nos chances ou pas l'oubli et
lorsque sur la passerelle de son bateau
il regarde autour de lui il ne peut pas
ne pas se dire que ces bateaux splendide
qu'il a autour de lui justement devant
lui sous ses yeux
et bien que ces bateaux ne tourmente pas
les anglais au delà de toute expression
et bien maintenant nous voici sur le
quai du mers-el-kébir 900 mètres de long
là où les navires de la force de rett de
l'amiral jean soul sont mouillés dans
l'ordre il y avait là bas dunkerque le
navire amiral un des plus beaux navires
de la flotte de l'époque 120 mètres de
long 26 8 500 tonnes plus loin le
cuirassé vieux cuirassé la provence il
ya il ya le sat bourg rival du dunkerque
merveilleux navire de votre moto michael
zager plus loin
le cuirassé la bretagne et labatt tout à
fait au bout
en atteste la vie ravitailleurs là en
face nous y ait du port saint-andré la
flottille de tapis hier et le contre
torpilleur sur les ordres d'apport
amiral
mais la vire sont face à la montagne
l'arrière amar est ici à des ans hier ça
va être tout problème fois par ailleurs
dit on que l'amiral aurait dû faire le
contraire l'appareillage aurait été plus
difficile
faut-il croire aussi que l'amiral aurait
dû disposer ses navires
autrement il fallait des fonds pour cela
je ne sais pas si la mayral l'est était
sûr va les avoir en fin de cette
question là on discutera dans toute
l'histoire de la marine à perte le temps
oui quand il est là l'amiral jean soul
sur le dunkerque où il a installé sa
marque
le pavillon tricolore avec quatre
étoiles ces quatre étoiles
palmer connaître que les anglais sont
venus pour reconnaissance
[Musique]
alors comme il veut en avoir le coeur
net il demande à l'un de ses officiers
le lieutenant de vaisseau du fait
d'aller à la rencontre de ceux hollande
parce qu on a déjà tout un gros dossiers
d'ordre de darlan avant l'armistice
darlan a fait savoir que tous les
commandes dans deux bâtiments les
responsables de la marine devait être
tranquille jamais la flotte française ne
serait remise adapte à l'ennemi et il a
confirmé récemment par un nord par des
instructions extraordinairement précise
les navires français serait démilitarisé
s'il le fallait uniquement dans des
ports français hors de la présence de
l'ennemi de l'adversaire dié si jamais
l'ennemi malgré les garanties ont été
données par la convention d'armistice
voulait mettre la main sur ces bateaux
eh bien il fallut le coup les laisse
aborder les autres équipes très précis
et puis si jamais
on pouvait par tous eh bien il fallait
aller aux états unis il a tous et orly a
aussi un ordre précis dieux différents
mais il faut bien dire qu'on de
l'armistice darlan a demandé qu'il n'y a
plus de contact avec les anglais alors
il sait tout cela
leur saoul mais ce bateau qui a la balle
qui annonce que comme la hollande de lui
parler il faut de même qu'ils sachent
que ça veut dire et voilà pourquoi le
lieutenant de vaisseau du fait des
descendants la vedette qui est là qui
attend toujours à la coupe et il faut le
voir ce du fait avec ses cheveux en
brosse vêtus de blanc
dites vous bien que pendant toute cette
journée tous ces officiers qui se
verront se rencontreront anglais
français sont tous vêtus de blanc parce
qu'il fait chaud et qu'on est vêtu de
blanc dans la marine quand il fait chaud
et la vedette du dunkerque s'élance dans
la rade par un souffle de vent
et lacoste au fox house
et voilà que j'aille de l'échelle deux
officiers hollande bon jour ils se
connaissent vous et dès qu'ils se
connaissaient tous
ils sympathisent ils ont toujours
sympathisé et hollande déclare a dit
c'est qu'il faut que j'aille sur le
dunkerque rencontré l'amiral ressoude
[Musique]
des jeunes garantit rien demandé evra
qui descend dans sa vedette et hollande
pencher sur le bastingage qui crie
insisté du fait insisté assister qu'est
ce que c'est peut-être cette action est
la vedette vogue vers le dunkerque vers
le dunkerque où la radio du bord avant
même que du fait soit de retour à cap
sur la longueur d'onde de l'amirauté un
médecin un étrange message déclarant que
la marine britannique salue la marine
française et qu'elle espère que cette
marine française va reprendre le combat
avec elle et que on attend tout de jean
soul et que d'ailleurs on lui dépêche
un homme qu'il connaît bien le
commandant hollande essais signés amiral
sommerville quoi sommerville dijon soul
je le croyais à la retraite sommes avril
il connaît une sonnerie hollande
sommerville et alors voici que si doute
il y avait dans un esprit se doutait
totalement effacé il comprendre
bah oui c'est le moment
le moment qu'on pouvait attendre
on les face à face
on va avoir à prendre une drôle de
décision
essai sur l'homme qui est chargé
d'apporter quoi au fait
des propositions
un ultimatum
et à ce moment précis voici le chef
d'état-major de jean soul clientes et
qui s'écrit que l'on vient de repérer la
base bien au delà de la jeter bien au
delà de la rade une énorme force
britannique
et oui on a reconnu les hommes devaient
y ont reconnu et comme on ne l'aurait-il
pas reconnu le rouge
quarante deux mille tonnes le fameux
coup
et puis ils ont connu la résolution le
valiant
[Musique]
et puis le porte avions ark royal et
puis une infinité de destroyers de
toutes sortes une vingtaine d stordeur
[Musique]
une force considérable
alors ouais gensoul comprend le sens du
message le sens de la présence du fab ce
temps
[Musique]
cette source elle est là pour appuyer la
demande qui vient d'être présenté et
c'est à ce moment là que du feu arrivent
et qu'il vient rendre compte à la murale
qui est très fâché lamerat à lui n'est
vraiment pas content gentille et le
prouve en donnant l'ordre immédiatement
d'intimé au fox en de l'ordre de
s'éloigner
partez le plus tôt possible ça veut dire
foutez moi le temps le phoque sens de
mon dieu qui est à portée des canons
sera d' obéir mais en s'en allant bien
toujours le signal optique vous
signalons que vedette commandant
hollande est en route pour le dunkerque
et alors voilà j'ai un soul qui est fou
de rage d'id encore landes mais jeunes
vivent je ne voulais pas l'anglais à
montbard aller du fait aller au devant
de lui en termes usées lui l'accès du
dakar et du fait voilà qui redescend
avec ses nombreux son uniforme blanc
dans la vedette et sandales
[Musique]
les faits on la voit s'approcher
l'embarcation du commandant de capitaine
hollande m voilà les deux vedettes née
année elles vont lier s'attacher
s'amarrer à une tonne qui est là qui
flotte qui est bien propice en
l'occurrence et hollande
il est encore plus exaltés plus excité
que tout à l'heure il en perd son
français et même en anglais ils bafouent
il bégaie par avance et pourtant ça
devait être le l'emmène de nouveaux
dunkerque au dunkerque
en soule va ouvrir
[Musique]
et dans l' enveloppe
il découvre la note de la mayral
sauvadet
une note qui commence par un exposé des
motifs comme toutes les notes sur le
courage la flotte française sur l'amitié
qui a uni depuis si longtemps depuis
l'entente cordiale le flotte britannique
et française sur les longs mois de
combats en commun sur aussi la grande
inquiétude qui menait à londres en
grande-bretagne
bien avant l'armistice et depuis que la
france a signé l'armistice
quant au sort de la flotte française le
gouvernement britannique ne peut
méconnaître que la flotte française est
la quatrième du monde
chacun le sait est que si elles tombent
entre les mains de la flotte allemand et
de la flotte italienne non négligeable
l'une et l'autre est bien la force ainsi
réuni viendra très facilement à bout de
la flotte britannique pourtant réputé
première du monde et voilà ce que
redoute le gouvernement britannique que
cette flotte tombe entre les mains des
allemands et des italiens
voilà pourquoi le gouvernement
britannique ne peut pas s'exposer à ce
risque
et voilà pourquoi lui amiral sommet
revêt est habilité à présenter à
l'amiral jose
trois heures grand à la flotte française
de raids
commandé par l'amiral gensoul accepte de
se joindre à la force britannique et les
deux flottes réuni décide de poursuivre
ensemble combat jusqu'à la victoire
commune contre l'allemagne hérité
[Musique]
et l'amiral sommerville ajoute si vous
n'acceptez aucune de mes trois
propositions
j'ai le regret de vous informer que je
coule rêve au bâton
c'est un marin jaune sous marins
français et les marins français ont
l'honneur particulièrement chatouilleuse
qu'est ce qu'il a retenu de cette note
britannique est bien c'est qu'il faut se
rendre aux anglais ce pâle des talons
quoi qu'il arrive il faut se rendre aux
anglais il ya des phrases qui le met
dans tous ses états équipage réduit
contrôle britannique
ça veut dire se rendre et a séduit le
matin il a répondu qu utile à la force
je répondrai par la force
voilà nouveau du fait dans sa vedette et
le voilà qui s'en va là bas au bout de
l'aragon hollande est toujours amarrée à
sa tonne
ils passent dans la vedette mais
hollande
comme il ya quelques marins sur la
vedette pour en assurer le
fonctionnement et bien voilà on y venait
dans la cabine
[Musique]
et il referme la porte derrière lui
alors vous savez la journée s'avance et
à 9 heures commence à faire très chaud
sur la rade de mers-el-kébir leur ce
soleil qui tape sur la tôle de la cabine
c'est plus de cabines c'est un hammam et
l'autre vers la porte est fermée
ils cuisent là dedans à petit feu et
leurs beaux uniformes blancs se collent
peu à peu sur leur poitrine mais ils n'y
pensent pas ces deux hommes là parce que
du fait comme unique
la réponse de lens ou la hollande ne
nous défendrons nous répondrons à la
force par la force et hollande est
littéralement atterré et d'une femme
vous ne comprenez pas notre
préoccupation
nous ne pouvons pas courir ce risque
c'est le sort de notre pays nous sommes
tout seul là devant cette masse
allemande qui est venu à bout de tout le
monde de riz compris de vous et dans
notre île nous sommes là nous les
attendons nous n'avons pas loin de
courir ce risque mais vous le courait
aucun risque du fait aucun et il montre
les ordres de darnand unis voilà ce
qu'annonce et d'armand nous avons
l'ordre de partir pour les états unis si
jamais les allemands ou les italiens
approcher est ce que vous croyez qu'ils
vous en donnerons autant d'irlande mais
si nous n'en avons pas le temps de nous
aborderons mais ils vous laisseront pas
vous abordé c'est presque un dialogue de
sourds et pourtant les hommes de darnand
sont formels et nous savons nous qui
connaissons la su que ce ne sont pas des
ordres
parce que nous connaissons la sphère de
toulon en 1942 et nous savons que même
les allemands a cours en s'approchant et
tenta de pas
[Musique]
je n'ai pas l'intention d'exécuter sept
ans
sans cet extraordinaire je vous ai parlé
à l'instant de la force des disciplines
qui existe dans la marine française
et voilà que rarement à l'intention de
ne pas exécuter l'ordre de son
gouvernement la flotte c'est son argent
il y tient plus qu'à sa vie alors la
flotte non la donner larhant cabu et ce
n'est pas une parole en l'air comme ça
échapper quelques mots dictés à le lui
le 3 juin devant jules moch nuls le va
récuser le témoignage de jules mann
darlan déclare je vais finir ma carrière
par un acte de splendides indiscipline à
la tête de la flotte
je vais rejoindre les anglais et voc ne
croit pas ses oreilles dans ses mémoires
il le dit c'est incroyable et quelques
jours après à briare quand churchill
s'inquiète parce que les défaites sont
maintenant si grand si total que
l'armistice est quelque chose qu'on peut
bien envisager car qu'il simple est
alors darlan si on signe l'armistice
vous allez en nous la flotte jamais
monsieur le premier ministre jamais
jamais la flotte ne tombera intacte
entre les mains des allemands et des
italiens
donc il ya une continuité absolue
[Musique]
dans les sprints à la continuité qui va
au delà de l'armistice investissent
implacable pour les armes terrestres
l'aviation
armistice totalement bienveillant
indulgent pour la marine l'article 8 de
la convention d'armistice qui précise
que l'allemagne n'a pas l'intention de
revendiquer à aucun moment la remise de
la flotte française que même gars la
signature du traité
l'allemagne s'engage à ne pas réclamer
la flotte française pourquoi cette
extraordinaire bienveillante
et voilà c'est que plus du fai veulent
convaincre qu'elle ne sera jamais remise
plus lui hollande reste persuadé que les
français ne pourront pas protéger leurs
flottes contre les entreprises
allemandes et italiennes
ces deux hommes face à face d'une
immense bonne foi
l'un et l'autre ne peuvent pas arrivé à
se mettre d'accord
quand tu fais va regagner le dunkerque
eh bien il trouve le navire en plein
branle bas de combat mais oui sur le
terme mars fait déjà depuis presque dix
minutes alors qu'il est parti
l'amiral jean soûlât déclenché le branle
bas de combat dans quel esprit et il en
soule cassure il a répondu qu'il
rendrait le coup pour coup qu'il
répondrait à la force par la force mais
il n'est pas vraiment persuadé que
sommerville donnera suite à ces menaces
il pense plutôt un bleu un énorme bluff
il n'arrive pas à se convaincre que les
amis les alliés d'hier puisse tirer
comme ça sur lui sur lui alors que
justement il n'est pas en position de
répondre faut bien comprendre parce que
le long de l'acheter les grands
bâtiments sont amarrés la coupe attaché
à l'acheter et l'avs en regardant vers
les terres très mauvaise position pour
répondre à un tir par un autre tir et
quand même gensoul reste dans une
perspective évident il faut négocier on
s'en tirera par la négociation et du fer
vont lui dire amiral leur fille n'est
pas convaincu le capitaine alla
bondy j'en suis retourné le voir avec
mon chef d'état major chef d'état-major
s'appelle dans b et voilà qu'il ouvrait
décembre dans la vedette elle et voilà
qu'ils repartent vers l'atome la vedette
de hollande est toujours amarré
et eux mêmes
kate
la vedette hollande regagne la leur et
quand ils les voient dans leur propre
embarcation hollande leur dit vous savez
en tant qu'officier à votre place
j'aurais exactement la même attitude
la différence entre les trois hommes qui
se sait pas
c'est que le capitaine hollande est le
seul à savoir quand et comment a été
conçue l'opération katapult oui parce
qu'il s'agit de l'opération 4 apple
elle a été conçue au lendemain de la
signature de la convention d'armistice
entre la france et l'allemagne
le principe est née au sein de
l'amirauté britannique et a été
immédiatement approuvé par le
gouvernement que préside ce winston
churchill
qu'est ce que c'est l'opération qu'a ta
peur
comme on n'a pas confiance toujours
cette vieille obstination dans la
méfiance comme on n'a pas confiance dans
la possibilité pour les français de
préserver leur flotte
on a décidé à s'en emparer ou de la kul
et donc qu'il y a des bateaux français
les équipages français
dans les ports britanniques on s'en
emparera on mettra les marins français
hors d'état de nuire
il y a une flotte alexandrie on s'en
emparera il y a une flotte à vercel
québec où l'on s'en emparera ou en la
couleur voilà le passé et on a tiré de
la retraite
l'amiral sommerville pour le mettre à la
tête de la force h qui doit précisément
venir à bout de la flotte française de
mers-el-kébir et quand ils arrivent à
gibraltar le vieil amiral sommerville et
ne sait pas très bien pourquoi on l'a
convoqué et quand on le lui révèle il
est atterré il va écrire à sa fin on
vient de me confier une odieuse mais en
lan france culotte il faut dire que
l'amiral cunningham à alexandrie
quand il apprend ce qu'on prépare n'est
pas non plus d'accord et ces deux
amiraux vont écrire vont télégraphié
allons dans leur disant il faut modifier
votre affaire on ne demande pas ça des
marins et ce sont les interventions
justement des amis au qui vont permettre
à londres deux légèrement humaniser le
plan primitif
c'est ça ma ville qui conseille
d'utiliser le capitaine hollande lui
parce qu'on le connaît parce qu'on aime
bien et pourra peut-être s'entendre avec
ces français plutôt que l ultimatum
tomberez là comme un couperet
[Musique]
et dans la nuit du 2 ou 3 juillet à pau
semences est appelée mans là où se
trouve un nombre important de bateaux
français avec des équipages français et
bien des commandos envahissent ses
bateaux les commandos britanniques
on sent par les bateaux en mai
l'équipage hors d'état de nuire et on va
le jeter dans des camps de prisonniers
ça se passe sans incident grave sauf à
bord du sous marin géant surcouf la
bagarre il ya cinq morts britanniques et
français
et là force vaches
amiral sommaire
von bergen mers-el-kébir où elle
arrivera le 3 juillet 1940
un peu après 7 heures du mans voilà
l'opération katapult un détail mais qui
compte dont il a lu les instructions
avec cet intitulé opération 14 cents à
bulles rayé et à la place il a mis
boomers
oui parce que 4 apple ce qu'est ce que
ça veut dire c'est qu'on arrose l'ennemi
d'engins de mort sans que l'ennemi
puisse se défendre alors lui il préfère
boomerang
[Musique]
préfère que l'autre mais on sait qui
c'est passé
c'est plus honorable et on comprend que
ce merveilleux et besoin de se persuader
que son opération soit très honorable
mais l'amiral jean sous lui ne sait pas
ce que c'est que l'opération quand apple
il faut se souvenir que le 3 juillet
1940 la france
est toujours plongé dans l'eau
[Musique]
ces millions de français qui ont quitté
leurs villes et leurs villages ils sont
toujours sur les routes
[Musique]
et le 1er juillet le gouvernement
français a quitté bordeaux parce que
l'armistice prévoyait que les allemands
allaient occuper bord dont ils né sur
les routes le gouvernement français est
ce que vous imaginez ça le président de
la république albert lebrun le président
du conseil philippe pétain et les
ministres et les députés et les
sénateurs et tout ce monde dans des
voitures qui s'étire en un interminable
cortège est derrière les camions qui
porte les papiers les archives de l'état
cet affront
[Musique]
et le 3 juillet eh bien on est entre
clermont ferrand et vichy et d'arles ans
est introuvable
mais heureusement darlan est un homme
d'ordre et il a installé l'état major de
la marine à nérac pourquoi nairas que
bien parce qu'il est de nérac justement
c'est son pays et celui qui commande
d'état major de la marine c'est logique
un maire luc et il réagi personnellement
et immédiatement une donne l'ordre à
toutes les forces de méditerranée de
cingler vers mers-el-kébir il faut
porter aide à chansons lui et puis la
boule un sourd vous avez bien fait de
répondre comme vous l'avez fait à la
force
je poserai la force
[Musique]
il y à un autre grand bâtiment français
autres orgueil de la flotte française qu
une riche faune dans le lieu s'est évadé
pour ne pas tomber entre les mains des
allemands il est à dacca mais voilà on
pense que le riz fonio va quitter et il
ya un bateau un croiseur britannique qui
est chargé de le surveiller et on envoie
de londres un message à se croiser au
henné bien intéressant cdc on sait pas
où va aller le jeu alors on dit au
croiseur britannique silva vers le nord
vous le laissez passer et vous laisse
kort skil valeur le nord il ya grande
penser qu'il va le rejoindre à port
britten se rallier au combat mais
attention s'il va vers l'ouest
ce sera probablement pour se rendre aux
antilles
et dans ce cas vous le coulerait qu'est
ce que savait donc si le richelieu voeux
de son plein gré sans qu'on lui en
intime l'ordre se rendre aux antilles il
faut l'en empêchèrent le cool en les
prenant donne même la pression les
progrès ou de rentrer temps
et pendant ce temps là à la même heure
le même jour on est en train de proposer
aux autres français de mers-el-kébir
d'année aux antilles attention avec
équipage réduit contrôle britannique
on sait le savais pas et nous qui savons
sommes tentés de nous dire qu'au fond
gensoul est excusable
parce qu est-ce que ce n'est pas un
piège cette affaire des antilles on
propose agences ou la sphère du
richelieu est bien une affaire de riches
annuel et qui approche de nous en
convaincre les gens sous l'île est
toujours devant son problème mais à
londres on trouve que sommerfeld bien
gentil on trouve qu'il fait durer le
plaisir et un ordre arrive de l'ombre il
faut en finir alors pas trésor
les sages de ce merdier à l'amiral jean
soul
si vous n'acceptez aucune de mes
propositions
j'ouvrirai le feu à 14 heures et je
pense que c'est seulement à ce moment
que j'en souris s'est dit qu'il ne
s'agissait pas seulement d'un bleu je
pense que c'est à ce moment que
jean soûlât compris que ceux qui étaient
là bas au delà de la jeter au delà de la
rade
des gens de la force h ces gens là
étaient réellement décidée à aller
jusqu'au bout
[Musique]
voici donc la plage allant du dunkerque
avec la chaîne principale
à ma gauche l'autre à ma droite le
piochel cette chaîne et saisit pas ses
mâchoires
elle est également et ses mâchoires se
nomme saisit pas cette taille et sa
taille sont bloqués par un groupe i un
coin a juste de quoi je vais partir tout
seul défaut son intention comme cette
intention sa part sa part normalement ce
qui a raté c'est le le pont lever la
goupille et le quoi et alors du
strasbourg des gens ont vu que soul
dunkerque on s'invite et on avait des
bars pour manoeuvrer la chaîne mais j'ai
pas de l'autre d'autres précisions la
grosse affaire c'est que il a fallu du
temps beaucoup de temps pour arriver à
réaliser cette manoeuvre assez simple la
suite de laquelle vous
et griffes sous et achêne foule bon ça
c'est l'avant alors ici nous sommes à
l'arrière du bateau en réalité le quai
est là et le leers en acier entoure un
bloc de béton énorme à cette hertz est
accroché le chêne le 30 mètres de long à
peu près la chaîne arrière qui a été
bien entendu mallet ici est pour faire
pour libérer le bateau il avait été
prévu de faire fonctionner le coq et
chapeau avec une tirette qui à vrai dire
était à 40 n'y est d'ailleurs un filin
c'est cette manoeuvre qui a été bloqué
pour des raisons encore mystérieuses
pour moi et qui nous a tenu sept minutes
sur le feu et puis vous allez vous
demander pourquoi justement ces bateaux
sont restés là pendant toutes ces heures
puisqu'ils n'étaient pas en bonne
position pour tirer
pourquoi gensoul ne les at il pas
disposer autrement
il suffisait de leur faire accomplir un
arc de cercle de leur faire quitter leur
mouillage pour les placer l'avant vers
le large
et alors là on aurait été à égalité
parce que le strasbourg et le dunkerque
au tyran ensemble sur l'aude et bien ça
valait bien le août qui rend sur le
dunkerque le strasbourg pigeon soul dans
les faits n'ont pas fait bouger ces
bateaux et pourquoi pour une raison très
simple c'est qu'il ne pensait toujours
pas qu'on en arriverait au pire et qu'il
fallait penser t-il négocier
donc il n'a pas fait bouger ces bateaux
se disant que s'il faisait bouger ces
bateaux les autres le verrai
n'oubliez pas que des avions survolent
sans cesse les bateaux français des
avions anglais
et que dès qu'il verrait les bateaux
français faire mouvement
il prendrait cela pour un acte de guerre
et ouvriraient le feu agences ou ne l'a
pas voulu
mais maintenant il faut tenter de
pouvoir faire face si on nous pour le
feu et il faut tenter d'éviter que l'on
n'ouvre le feu alors justement à 13h30
une demi heure avant le moment fatal
gensoul envoie un message je n'ai pas
l'intention ma part je suis prêt à
recevoir à mon bord vos représentants
pour discussion aux normes et dès qu'il
reçoit à 13h50
ce message de jean soul sommerville
annuler son ordre de feu
il était en dix minutes avant et deux
hommes vont voguer vers le dakar dans
une vedette
ces deux hommes c'est le capitaine
hollande toujours y aille au fond par
exemple ça change il connaît bien les
éléments les problèmes et il est
accompagné par un autre officier
britannique dev
[Musique]
et voilà les deux hommes qui a bon dos
d'un cartel a coupé ni d'un gap
honneur qui leur sont dues aux normes
réglementaires
[Musique]
où
et les deux anglais conduit dans la
cabine de l'amiral jean soul mais comme
il y as branle bas de combat on na vi et
les hublots et là aussi c'est une
fournaise il ne faut pas perdre de vue
dans toute cette histoire cette chaleur
qui les entourent qui les cernent de
partout cette écrasante chaleur à mesure
que la journée avance et dans cette
cabine de l'amiral les hommes qui
cherchent à trouver une solution il en
soule qui énumère de nouveau les
arguments qui font que les anglais ont
tort ils ont tragiquement tort ils ne
doivent pas croire que la marine
française sera remise aux allemands et
aux italiens
et oui ils sont tellement loin les uns
des autres et ils vont quitter le bord
et ils vont descendre dans leurs voeux
tête et ils vont s'éloigner nous savons
que hollande en bas dans sa vedette du
fait là haut au bastingage ont échangé
un dernier regard navré désespérés parce
qu'ils savent que c'est fini parce
qu'ils savent qu'on ne se parlera plus
parce qu'ils savent qu'on ne négociera
plus parce qu'ils savent que maintenant
ce qui est en route
fait rare et qu'on n'y échappe pas
ici nous sommes sur le forme du santon
318 m au dessus du niveau de la mer de
là on voit la saleté pire d'une façon
admirable n'y a pas un détail qui
échappe et avec cette montagne qui fait
le fond de ce terrain cette montagne
noire et avec l'épreuve de santa cruz
qui descendront également dans la mer
forment une espèce de deux lieux de
combat pour le pour les dieux et pour
les hommes ce qui va ce que on voit de
près du cap blanc
et la brume la bohème n'est pas là
l'amiral jean soûlât temps et la bohème
népal elle est là bas au nom et les
navires anglais sortent de la brume est
rentré joue une sorte de ballet environ
13,4 mm d'ici il y avait autrefois les
télés des télémètres est apprécié ils
n'ont pas servi à grand chose parce que
il ya eu un manque de liaison avec les
corps entier il y avait une batterie
côtière à fait remarquable la brune la
bohème on peut le dire à notre avis les
rayons soul et dans quelques instants
le feu va commencer
c'est un message de sa marine si l'une
de mes propositions n'est pas accepté
d'ouvrir le feu à 16h30 au nord fièvre
sur les embarcations sur les bâtiments
français
[Musique]
on se prépare on largue les amarres
enfin sauf de la care
[Musique]
16h56 faire et c'est la première salle
tango les obus sont tombés au delà et
maintenant il n'y a plus assez jeune et
on peut faire mouvement les contracteurs
pilleurs ont quitté leurs mouillages de
saint-andré il s'avance dans la rade
vers la passe le strasbourg merveilleux
le strasbourg a quitté la jetée est déjà
amorcé un virage vers la gauche
enfin la deuxième salle
ce ne sont pas des enfants de choeur les
pointeurs britannique la première salle
était trop courte
la deuxième salve s'abat sur la jetée
elle-même tuant tous les hommes qui s'y
trouvaient y compris des promeneurs il y
avait des preuves faire passer au sol
et là au cap blanc sur les battre sur le
bretagne le grand bretagne
le grau d'agde
le bretagne qui est atteint dans ses
oeuvres vives
et un immense incendie qui se déclenche
à l'instant le commandant voudrait
manoeuvrer pour que cet incendie ne se
propage pas de part et d'autre vers les
bateaux qui l'entourent impossible les
machines ne donne rien parce que tout
brûle tout explose c'est affreux et
l'énorme masse va s'incliner
le gîte de plus en plus et la voilà qui
se renverse songer à ces familles qui
sont à l'intérieur les mille hommes
d'équipage tout comme en bas de cet état
tous se renverse de mazuch la 112
l'enfer on n'ose même pas y penser ceux
qui sont sur le pont qui sont à la mer
mais le mazout s'est étalée sur la mer
il flotte tanks dans le base août il
s'englue dans le mazout il se noie dans
le mazout
il avale du mazout et il coûte 900 morts
sur le bretagne plus de 40 officiers
et pourtant voilà les contre-torpilleur
qui s'avance vers la passe
le strasbourg qui les suit le mogador
qui va passer faire encore une seule
voilà le monde alors atteint
l'équivalent qui prennent écoutant les
autres contre torpilleur qui passe et
les mines magnétiques qui avait déposé
là les anglais bien tout le monde passe
malgré les mines magnétiques c'est
extraordinaire et le strasbourg qui
passe et qui est en mer
[Musique]
pense que poursuivre le massacre est une
chose inutile un message à l'adresse des
centres villes
je demande le cessez-le-feu et puisqu'on
voulait un pavillon carré ou risque
pavillon carré est immédiatement
sommerville cesse de feu parce que lui
aussi a fait les mêmes constatations
on a atteint le but ce n'est pas la
peine de continuer ce qui compte c'est
de rejoindre le strasbourg
parce que si on laisse partir le
strasbourg on a perdu à moitié la
bataille
[Musique]
alors la nuit en complément on se voit
il est baissé
dans les infirmeries on opère
com
lâcher
et c'est heureux
et le lendemain et bien on enterrera les
morts
elle à meyrals gensoul par là il est
très bien le mirage en soule pas un mot
contre les anglais mais une phrase s'il
y a une tache sur un pavillon
et si sur un mois que ce n'est pas sur
le nôtre et puis alors il ya le vieil
amiral esteva avec sa barbe qui donne
une interview
mais qui dit vous savez les anglais pas
voir mais il n'y a pas de raison que
dunkerque il est presque pas talent
dunkerque c'est peu de chose quelques
jours de réparation il sera à même de
reprendre la mer et vous pensez bien que
l'interview les anglais vous l'entendrez
chant soul gensoul qui dit mais qu'est
ce tu la laisses tu vas et voilà qui
reviennent pour achever l'oeuvre les
anglais une escadrille d'avions qui vont
bombarder le 5 juillet le dunkerque et
la seyne
[Musique]
vingt-cinq mille litres d'eau il a
sombré avec 25 mille litres d'eau dans
ces 25 mille tonnes
voilà voilà la sphère de mers-el-kébir
et je comprends lui le roi
je le comprends lui qui s'interrogent
depuis 43 ans est lui qui se demande
toujours pourquoi
en fait
nous qui savons nous sommes sûrs d'une
chose c'est que mersen qui est bien
n'était pas nécessaire
puisque nous savons que la presse
française était réellement en état de se
dérober aux entreprises des allemands et
des italiens
je vous rappelle un nom au corps tout
l'eau donc il n'était pas nécessaire
d'entreprendre et d'accomplir la sphère
de mers-el-kébir mais voyez vous je me
souviens de winston churchill le vieux
lion le vieux bulldogs il a dit bien
plus tard il a dit moi j'ai pensé à
d'antan
moi à la face du monde et de l'europe
mais je t'ai mers-el-kébir
et oui en fait l'angleterre le 3 juillet
c'est un pays en qui plus personne ne
croit la france a été écrasée en un mois
l'angleterre n'est pas armée elle n'a
rien présentement ce sont des civils ils
ont distribuer des bâtons pour arrêter
l'invasion allemande si elle se produit
on n'a plus confiance en angleterre ni
les anglais en le même ni les autres en
angleterre et voilà que tout à coup à
cause de mers-el-kébir on va se rendre
compte partout dans le monde de
l'infiniment détermination des bretons
et ce sera la bataille d'angleterre
gagner dans les airs contre la luftwaffe
ligue 1
[Musique]
peut-être n'aurait-il pas gagné la
bataille d'angleterre simple
mersen kabylie
et finalement gagné la bataille
d'angleterre s'était nous sauver tous
tentent au sol mais que ses projets sa
complice au détriment de la flotte
française qu'avait toujours jalousé les
anglais ça devait être quand même une
vague idée qui lui trottait par la tête
alors au moment de répondre au pourquoi
on pense à deux hommes on pense agences
où l'on pense à turku et pour gensse où
l'on se dit que sans doute aurait-il
était difficile de faire autrement
et peut-être de faire mieux
[Musique]
cimetière marin de mers-el-kébir là haut
une partie du mât d'artimon de la
bretagne est resté au fond de l'eau du
port plus d'un an avec tous les marins
ont retiré et en a fait un ossuaire
et puis derrière des autres tombes des
marins haute on reconnaissait du corps
au dessus les canons les offres de la
marine et puis de mots honneur et patrie
notre vie de la marine honneur
une tombe le temps qui n'est pas comme
les autres une tante qui la tombe de
l'amiral alors les gens se mouiller
peut-être non la maire-adjointe relais
était un endroit dont on ne voit pas la
mer non c'est la tombe de quelqu'un dont
il ya peu de gens qui se figurent qu'il
est la véritable la tombe de l' amiral
de la flotte darlan taper lui le
responsable de mers-el-kébir c'est lui
qui avait mis la flotte et mers-el-kébir
et puis françois darlan l' amiral de la
flotte d'arles en espagne arrivé le
parti avec les mecs sains deux parties
avec les anglais puis de regarder la
marine française à la france
et puis ensuite il est allé voir hitler
et puis ensuite il est une des cinq ans
qu'on sait et après c'est le destin a
justement en 1964 l'algérie était déjà
indépendante mais bersac tes dires
étaient restés dans les accords avec la
france un aviso la ramener et tous les
généraux et amiraux en exercice et elle
a sauvé le fils de darlan aussi guetter
l'a aidé à leur lot funèbre lui ont été
rendus
est il de la lah dernier quand je suis
venu la plaque de sa tombe n'était pas
briser comme elle l'est on lisait bien
amiral de la flotte françois darlan
morts pour la france
- la question que je me pose c'est à
quoi ça sert
d'avoir été amiral de la flotte d'avoir
fait de la marine française la quatrième
du monde
à quoi ça sert tout ça à quoi ça sert à
cette gloire ses rêves si lorsque des
navires français viennent encore
mouillée à mers-el-kébir personne ne
vient vous voir et vous laisse seul mais
à quoi ça sert seulement d'ici on voit
la mer
[Musique]